we got this story from the daily mail
this is big news Tucker Carlson
interviewed Devin Archer this was
surprising I can't believe he got him
Devin Archer tells Tucker Carlson Joe
knew he was on calls with Hunter's
business partners associate says Biden
brand was absolutely key to business
deals and reveals the thank you letter
the then VP sent him so this is it in
the interview let me play this clip for
you real quick from Tucker's uh show
there you go these are not business guys
this is the vice president of the United
States he's not allowed to be working on
businesses with foreign governments
while he's vice president
I don't think not that I know of
here he is
he is right amazing he knew what he was
doing Devin Archer confirms Joe Biden
knew what he was doing Joe Biden was
using his son as a proxy so that he
could run business deals while vice
president and aside from Devon Archer's
testimony to Congress he's now on Tucker
Carlson with a thank you letter from the
VP Biden said he never talked to any of
Hunter's Associates
that's the stupidest lie imaginable he
could have at least tried and said like
of course I know Hunter's Associates I
don't work with them but yeah how do I
not know my son's doing business with he
comes by for dinner yeah well that's
their business I'm in government they're
doing business no he said I've never
talk to him at all and now the media is
like trying to Gaslight and what was
that one article said it's long been
known that Joe Biden was speaking with
Hunter Biden's business associates
actually not at all yeah I mean we found
out recently but here you go meanwhile
Donald Trump is being indicted for like
the 8 millionth time and uh what is it
like Mark Rubio's on to tweet out we got
some strongly word strongly worded
letters yep finally so the other day all
the law is the cudgel and the way the
the way our legal system is with so many
laws you all there's always something
that you can get someone for and this is
a perfect example of it you have Trump
that's doing all these silly little
things and maybe technically by the
letter of the law there's some law
somewhere that says they can't do X Y or
Z but then with someone with him is
clearly not breaking it there's not a
will to actually enforce it yeah it's
even worse because then like maybe it's
the worst thing that ever happened in
the country but at least Trump is a
Russian spy is kind of cool all this
stuff is just boring yeah you know Trump
being a Russian spy you're imagining you
know Trump's got like this weird Gadget
kit in his jacket and he like pulls out
a little tiny earpiece and he's like
Vladimir I'm in played by Dalton sitting
in the Oval Office we did it yeah go for
eagle Commander Dolph Lundgren can play
him in the movie from Rocky IV he's all
ripped Trump just super ripped and sing
at the Oval Office well just like the
the like the taxes that was like five
scandals ago and nobody remembers
candles and nobody cares because it's
just like they said it's just a cudgel
that they use to get like Trump's taxes
oh yeah particularly right it's just a
cudgel that they use as a as a weapon
against him because the law is used in
an adversarial manner here I think it's
because like I said before they're just
trying to slow him down and I think
that's why the media is so freaked out
by The credibility of the allegations
against Hunter and and Joe uh the fact
that this guy can produce a thank you
letter is is kind of hilarious when
they're over here like we spent millions
of dollars on this investigation and we
think maybe these things happened I I
think it was a text between Hunter Biden
Devin Archer where Devin is like why is
your family destroying my life and
trying to put me in prison I was like
why why is your dad's Administration
into pointy he's trying to destroy my
life and Hunter's like this is the cost
of a free country or something like that
what it actually sounds like is you were
of you're no longer of use to these
people and now they're disposing of the
loose threads you got to clean up shop
you don't want people to find out what
was going on and Devin Archer Tony
bobulinski they've been able to come out
and provide evidence
into the criminal or Shady dealings of
the uh Biden family do you think Joe
ever looked at Devin our turn was like I
wish I could trade you for Hunter but
people already know what Hunter looks
like because that's really the biggest
loose end of the Biden family I mean
that guy is just leaving laptops
everywhere and children in his wakes you
know what I mean like this seems like
the biggest weekend but there's nothing
you can do about it so this is what the
Biden family has created for themselves
but most people are still like I said
they still have their mind made up we
covered a thing earlier today where like
Amber Heard remember Amber Heard like
last year she pooped on the bed but uh
like the other thing where like she like
lost a brand deal with L'Oreal and they
they showed all these letters from women
who still to this day talk about her
like she's the greatest thing that ever
happened to feminism and she helped me
realize how important it was if you if
you heard depending on where you get
your information from you just don't
know and you're just going to be tricked
into believing that this is a good guy
so the average person who doesn't pay
attention to the news cycle doesn't hear
any of this stuff that's going on with
Joe there's the actual clip of him
saying I made this as a quid pro quo
quid pro quo in Ukraine and nobody knows
about it nobody cares because the
average person isn't paying attention
and that's who they've weaponized the
dumbing down of America through
corporate press yeah and I I actually
think teams I think it's somewhat
inverted I think people in this country
have been stupid for a long time I
should say ignorant uh because of mass
media you only got information from a
few sources and now with the internet
we're becoming more educated and
informed on what's happening but it's
targeted you're choosing where you're
getting your media from you or I or
everyone here may be privy to looking at
right and left-wing media the average
person doesn't do that and we just
thought we didn't have that 20 years
exactly the average person just follows
CNN because whether we believe CNN or
not they think that they're getting
informed by somebody from there or MSNBC
because it's even more targeted than it
used to be the point is that 20 years
ago CNN was your only choice obviously
there's Fox CB CBS ABC but they all said
the exact same things for the most part
now you have the ability to have
dissident media I don't think the
average like I just I feel like the
average person still doesn't look at
that as a value of course I think that's
what I'm saying is we we assume now that
they're lying to us like no they've
always been lying to us we just have the
ability to go online and communicate
with each other I think part of it is
politics are like sports teams I like
some people feel to their core that they
are a capital r republican they are a
capital D Democrat and nothing you say
will convince them that anyone on their
team did anything wrong I mean think
about actual sports teams we'll go get
uh players who commit very obvious and
well-documented case of like domestic
violence and the team is like oh yeah
that was the worst anyways he's going to
sit out a couple games and then we'll
bring him back like people aren't saying
I'm now renouncing this team which is
supporting you know some terrible person
who doesn't live in the values that I
support with Biden it's very easy for
people on in the Democratic party say
like well I'm a Democrat I only want
Democrats to win right now my options
are Joe Biden and his crazy family or
RFK Jr or Marianne Williamson if she's
still hanging out and that's it and so
they're going to cling and defend Biden
because they are trapped right if you're
back since well you're gonna stick with
your team same for Republicans there are
Republicans who will say you know I am
this kind of Republican and Trump can
never be and I this is how the
Republican Party should be like they
become completely obsessed with the team
they think they have to show loyalty to
even when the team lets them down
Kennedy Williams in 2024. oh my gosh
let's go I feel like those podcasts
would be amazing you got to think the
demographic of people who actually vote
is typically older too and so you were
mentioning the dissonant media point and
it's like I do feel like we're almost
experiencing like a rise in class
Consciousness but like with this new
dissonant Medias and stuff coming up but
let's be real typically the older
Generations aren't quite buying on to it
so this is gonna be a lagging Trend that
takes a while to come into place but um
oh no go ahead how polite I'll moderate
here I lost my train what were you gonna
say I was waiting for your question no
but now like not feel bad like the but
the but the Democrats are the ones
weaponizing influencers and the youth
because they want to get the youth vote
and they want to get people out in
voting more than they were before right
yes like let's be real most of them yeah
and I feel like democrats for a long
time they're like no no it doesn't
matter who you vote for we just want you
to vote but specifically here are the
candidates you should vote for I mean
there are things that you know the
Republican party and a lot of other
political parties that are out there
could have done meaning they could have
treated the get out the vote effort like
it was this you know Trojan hearse we're
just trying to talk to young people what
actually was obviously Democrats trying
to connect with youth voters uh I think
that's again why the Civic engagement
conversation that that vivekan Swami
brings up is really interesting because
I think people do especially now they
have access to Alternative forms of
media online feel called to do something
right if you get to hear all this awful
stuff all the time you can either
collapse and depression or act and I
think that's what people want and that's
why you know
the Democratic party is still pointing
fingers and they're becoming less
appealing
yes thank you thank you for your consent
sometimes I feel like I come to the show
and just like talk to myself in the
mirror for an hour which is like maybe
not the best
I don't know man
I'm just thinking about
2024 is around the corner and we are
lucky right now to be we here's what
we're doing we're all sitting on the
beach
Miami Beach in fancy chairs with
coconuts going all that Joe Biden you
hear about this and then off in the
distance there's the biggest hurricane
we've ever seen and it is coming
where we are right now is the chill time
with all the craziness they're doing
with the Devon Archer stuff with the
indictments against Trump that's just us
seeing lightning off in the distance
what's gonna happen next year we're
talking I mean dude we're talking five
or six months from now
so we're looking at about what eight
months no not even seven months until
the primary
Trump's first criminal trial is going to
be then
it is going to be Bonkers could you
imagine if it's not though like it's
just nothing happens and we're sitting
here and like nobody cares about
politics nobody's watching anymore and
they're just like oh we don't care
anymore that's it Biden wins again as no
one really talks about it
it is funny how like I feel like in the
past used to be able to actually make
more accurate political predictions to
some extent but now we've gotten to the
point to where there are so many factors
and so many crazy things like just Trump
and Biden alone between the two of them
the two scandals going on there like
those are both insane scandals on their
own just like I mean in different ways
obviously but I don't know it's just
it's like trying to predict the future
or have an idea of what's going on like
I was just talking on the airport to
somebody today but then the airplane
today about like whether Biden will run
and I'm like I have no idea like I mean
it seems a silly idea to do so but the
same time we're getting so close do you
really not I I I don't know like how do
you get another four years of this guy
without actually making a clone I don't
know I think I I think there's a strong
possibility that in Biden's old age and
with his existing ailments something
happens to him
and I imagine what would be
for the Democrats the most beneficial
thing imaginable
would be if like Gavin Newsom is at a
Biden rally
and talking about how he's here to
support Joe Biden and Joe Biden's the
greatest president and then Biden
suffers like some health ailment or
something he fell on stage that one time
maybe he has a stroke
well like you've children in the
sandbags but he's fallen upstairs but
imagine the scenario where Biden's is
speaking at some kind of Rally or
whatever or just on TV maybe because I
can't really muster up anybody to come
to a Biden rally Gavin Newsom is there I
think it's likely going to be him and
then Biden collapses Gavin runs to to
save him all on TV get a medic in here
and then there's this oh the news oh no
oh Joe Biden cue all the conservatives
being like we don't like the guy but
we're really sad about what happened to
him Gavin Newsom steps up and starts
talking about how you know it's a time
for leadership he's being interviewed by
everybody because he was there every
news Outlet sits him Outlet sits him is
down and says like what was it like what
do you what do you think what now who's
gonna step up will you
and there you go deep state news of 2024
a great idea no I'm not taking notes
they're looking through their book going
like
how I'm imagining so we're talking about
if Donald Trump didn't call the police
like it didn't order the police shut
down the the 529 Insurrection and let
antifa just run rampant he'd be
president because the narrative would be
inverted and you know I you know Michael
Mouse is saying oh the media would still
lie about him but I'm like yeah but they
wouldn't have the j6 narrative they
would have the extremism of the far left
and regular Americans would be asking
why this happened yeah I'm trying to
think about let's think forward in that
context like what could the Democrats do
what could Trump do to guarantee a
victory and obviously Joe Biden is not
the guy Trump's already beating him in a
whole bunch of polls he's tying with or
beating him and so everyone speculated
that Joe Biden won't be the guy but how
do you get Joe Biden out if he bows out
it's it's weakness in the Democratic
party it's got to be something that can
pass the torch if Joe Biden went on
stage and said you know I'm just too old
so Gavin Newsom ladies and gentlemen nah
would never fly but if there's a hero
moment for Gavin where he steps in to
try and save Biden that gives him every
PR opportunity in the book yeah
especially because they don't want him
to pick another white man over Kamala
Harris because there was a time when I
think the Democratic party really wanted
her to be the obvious choice they were
hoping Biden would be a one-term
president and that she would ask the
vice president be the next one to
represent the party because she's
diverse and a lady and you know whatever
else important uh so they have to find a
way to make it so that Gavin you know
gracefully as a hero becomes the obvious
one it's not that she's being overlooked
it's that he just happened to be in this
you know what's the justification for
Gavin being in the Press 24 7 and lit to
an election because he was there and
they're gonna say
Gavin you are heroically on camera seen
rushing to the aid of Joe
what was that like what was going
through your head he'll be like his last
words to me were yup you gotta take the
helm something like that I don't even
know people would buy it anymore no he's
gonna say he's gonna say you know tell
Jill I love her
and take care of my kids and then
Gavin's gonna start crying and he's
gonna be like you got it man and he's
gonna clench his hand and then they're
gonna be like wow Gavin Newsom take care
of my six I mean seven grandkids
that statement made me brutal crazy I
know I was on another show on Friday
when that came out but I was the fact
the arrogance of these people to be like
we care about all of our grandchildren
including Navy who we just happened to
learn about 30 seconds ago like where
have you been this whole time this is
what I mean by like how can anyone look
at the Biden family and be like four
more years this is going so well I think
the average person just doesn't know any
of this is I really do I really do think
that they don't know that his family
life is this screwed up they don't even
know about the diary they don't know
about the laptop that's why the Navy
statement came out in People magazine
they didn't say it to the New York Times
They said it to People magazine because
they're trying to present themselves as
like a let us get out in front of this
luckily People magazine all kinds of
flowers have already covered the fact
that this you know super great guy
hunter just ditched his other kid and
doesn't want to use last name like I
just don't understand this family and
their appeal so unless the Democrat my
only counter to the the Gavin Newsom
rushing to uh Joe Biden's Aid story
would be like if the Democratic party
starts to turn tables and be like we had
no idea that he was working on these
deals and this is this is dishonor to us
I don't know that they could execute it
perfectly I don't think so then it's
collateral damage yeah then what he does
is he's Joe's finally going to sniff one
kid too many and Gavin heroically steps
between him Gavin's gets one of Gavin's
yes and then in what happens
no pushes him away I got it Joe at an
event goes to sniff a kid and Gavin
heroically steps in between making Joe
accidentally sniff Gavin triggering the
stroke
interesting amazing
that's the hero narrative they need from
him like we didn't know Joe was doing
any of this it's weird his schedule and
see when he and Gavin Newsom are
appearing on stage together and we all
need to brace ourselves to get Joe Biden
out of this it needs to be a heroic
Retreat it could theoretically be
something like he has a health scare and
then has to publicly announce that he's
done everything he can but as you know
this is a tough job and it's been very
taxing about the young man I used to be
that's a light possibility or terminal
he'd have to be like I actually only
have six months and then and then he
looks at the camera and says America I
ask you for one thing with my final
statement to you
vote Democrat man we're gonna we're
gonna fix it don't let these Fashions or
something like that yeah I'm headed to
the big ice cream shop up in the sky
you're right you're still right that
like they would need to really find a a
big way of introducing Gavin Newsom over
Kamala Harris because I think if the
Biden administration of Democrat Party
turned the Kamala Harris they're going
to isolate a lot of Voters but with
numbers like that who who even wants I'm
not saying she's popular I'm just saying
there are a lot of people who feel like
the Democratic party needs to be led by
a woman who is of color and to turn it
over to another white man would be bad
if they if they can't run Kamala Kamala
doesn't have the support but they will
be mad if they don't think about it she
doesn't have the how do I say cognitive
faculties
with Joe Biden we prove we don't need
that yeah that's true yeah who who is
who is of higher mental status
Michelle Michelle Obama I thought that
was gonna be a thing so my so my
understanding is that they do want to
run Michelle but Michelle doesn't want
to run I don't blame her yeah I mean
it's it's like the most relatable thing
I've ever heard who wants to run like
seriously who would I can't even believe
Vivek wants to run it's like y'all are
crazy especially given that like Obama's
there I mean they're very wealthy now
they don't need to do this they own like
three production companies in Italy
she's having a great time yeah can you
imagine the stress can you imagine the
campaigns against her especially the
memes all the Big Mike stuff and all
that stuff like be I don't know it'd be
I mean I'd love it it'd be fun to watch
but uh also like Hillary Clinton held
office before she ran like Michelle
Obama was the first lady and then was
like yeah and we're in it would be such
a
such a cringy diversity point like I
don't know I wouldn't want to be there
what are your credentials I slept with
the previous president
oh that you know hey school lunch
program stuff yeah yeah she wanted kids
to lose weight I guess but that's not
that's not good in today's day and age
you can't say that now to rewind a
little bit back to the point I was
making about you know we're sitting on
the beach looking at the storm off in
the distance we know the storm's coming
so what do we do now right what are what
are what what do we do to prevent the
worst elements of the storm if anything
could be done right I'm not I'm not sure
humans have the ability to fight a
hurricane off so I think the reality is
going to be
don't like get ready in a matter of
speaking meaning like do you know where
the eggs are in your house you know uh
uh do you have somewhere to go in the
event of mass unrest in cities because
that's extremely likely
I think we're gonna see a ton of rioting
throughout the summer but I could be
wrong who knows there's a decent
possibility that like nothing happens no
and we're just like wow nothing happened
there's a lot of political bickering in
the news like we're seeing now but I I
really feel like
when Trump
his trials are coming up
he's going to be in multiple criminal
trials the news is going to be the
craziest you've ever heard
CNN is going to be salivating they're
already salivating the idea of covering
what are we on four three I think but
the with with yeah yeah I mean with
Fulton County so you've got New York
classified documents 2020 and Fulton
County you're gonna have four different
criminal proceedings all going on around
the exact same time
maybe what actually happens is that
people just turn the TV off figuratively
I mean like I can't track all these
criminal proceedings I'm done maybe
that's what they want to happen this is
a good point yeah what's the point right
they want people to say he's guilty by
sheer volume of things that he's uh but
they don't have the opposite effect I
think in for some people it'll have
it'll be too much noise like how could
he possibly be guilty of all of these
things all of these trials have to
happen at once like you can't take it
all in so you start to say like I just
don't believe you and I don't want to
have this conversation anymore or I
don't want to watch any more of this
I've seen both on YouTube comments just
today I said someone one person is
saying like well if my I don't want
someone that's been indicted like why
would I want to like someone that's been
indicted for anything another person was
saying he's been indicted for four
different things like there's no way
that he's been indicted for all there's
no way he did all these things how would
he have the time to do that and and do
all this there's just no way it was
possible so it goes both ways nothing's
gonna win out a lot of people would take
the where there's smoke there's fire yes
well why why would they lie why would
they lie about that and they'll just
assume that well if four different
jurisdictions all came to this
conclusion of their own accord mind you
there was no backroom dealings at all
I'm sure uh that he must be guilty there
must be moral Republican attorneys yeah
there must be no Republican prosecutors
anywhere right they're all like you know
what I'm gonna do we're in West Virginia
I'm gonna go to like find a local
prosecutor's office and I'm asking why
he's a Democrat
and then well I'm not I'll be like come
on if you're if you were actually a
republican you'd be criminally charging
these people right the the the the
Hillary Clinton stuff took place in West
Virginia they ran elections Nationwide
her name was on the ballot right so when
she tried to defraud the the country and
the the fraud led to a massive 30 plus
million dollar investigation as to
whether Trump was secretly working for
the Soviet Union how come there's no
there's no criminal charges for that
because the Republicans are timid and
Democrats Play for Keeps I think it's
because Republicans are Democrats and
they're just pretending they're not
they're going the speed limit but but
it's but but that's the saying but I'm
like no actually they're probably Kevin
McCarthy has gone behind the scenes and
high-fiving you the party right yeah
we're talking about Trump here so it's
not really so much a left or it's right
thing as there's establishment versus I
guess you could say dissident it would
be a good way to describe the other
energy and I think Tim's right I think
there will be people checking out but I
think that will be more the right to
some extent roughly the people that are
in the know because they know like this
is nonsense you're just throwing a bunch
of stuff at it it's just static at this
point but I think on the flip side the
left we may see especially if he
inevitably probably gets off or if he
does get elected they'll be screeching
the streets all over again we'll see all
that nonsense again but I think the
right is going to start retreating
locally like the the people of the right
like the the voter base they're gonna
start retreating embracing localism and
and honestly that's kind of the better
way to go yeah I think this is sort of
an answer to your question of like if
we're on the beach right now and we know
the storm is coming when do we decide to
leave the the beach and go make sure our
home's okay I would like to see you know
we might not be able to stop whatever
crazy fighting is about to happen on the
federal level but it would be
interesting to see people say like well
how do I protect myself at home how do I
insulate it who runs her school board
who runs her school board who runs your
elections who's running your town what
what decisions are they making because
again in some ways the worst part about
all of this is that it's a big
distraction from the the tiny decision
what feel feels like tiniest but they're
actually massive in your own life right
they make all the different personal
relationships that people live around
you the decisions for for zoning or
anything else that happens locally to
you that stuff is way more likely to
affect you on a daily basis than any of
the large-scale national politics yeah
so to Tim's Point like it's it's that we
have to decide it's time to leave the
beach and go make sure our homes are
okay I don't know if I agree with that
um I certainly agree that local politics
are extremely important but it's it's
probably a balance of sorts I mean the
stuff we saw with the federal government
ESG woke policies the Department of
Education the curriculum stuff they push
you've got like the complaints over
Common Core which was several years ago
now you've got the schools pushing all
this you know gratuitous content all
this comes to the federal level sure but
the only way to stop it coming down from
third level is have someone fighting
right and so I'm saying it's not that
you can ignore the federal election I'm
just saying like it would be good to not
get so lost on if or Trump did this or
whatever that you don't know who's
running in your own I just feel like to
some extent the federal move is almost a
lost cause maybe not but I think there
is something for example one thing I
liked about DeSantis is he was making
moves within his state where it was kind
of in a sense distancing himself
somewhat from the federal government and
doing his own thing uh kind of almost a
soft nullification soft session to some
ways and I personally would like to see
that energy continue to go forward and
start separating yourself further where
you can so that federal government has
less effect on your life thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time